[Musique]
karim s'avère bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin on directe ur rt france
alors on le sert la situation au yémen
elle a été qualifiée de pire crise
humanitaire au monde par l'onu
alors cette décision américaine quelles
conséquences très concrètes sur pour la
population yéménite
elle va avoir deux conséquences sur le
terrain yéménite tente un pointu
humanitaire vous l'avez souligné ça
risque effectivement de rendre plus
difficile la tâche des organisations
humanitaires qui ont déjà d'ailleurs
sonné auront tiré la sonnette d'alarmé à
propos de la mise en oeuvre de cet
accord en fin de cette décision de
sanction qui je le rappelle quand même
d'abord été être validé par le congrès
donc elle va rendre plus difficile le
travail des humanitaires puisqu'on sait
très bien que pour accéder aux zones
contrôlées par les conti il faut passer
par eux donc ça va effectivement
pénalisé la population ensuite il ya les
certain nombre de mécanismes financiers
mis en oeuvre dans le cadre des
sanctions qui vont paralyser les
transactions de 2 donc de 2,6 avec
l'étranger et notamment les importations
têtes qui vont encore une fois pénaliser
la population est juste un point de vue
politique les chances minces certes mais
qui existe encore dans un dialogue
ce risque d'être complètement anéanti
entre les acteurs à pernes puisque on
nous rappelle quand même que depuis fin
2010 8
l'onu a engagé un processus de dialogue
en suède entre différentes y compris
l'arabie saoudite qui risque aujourd'hui
malheureusement d'être totalement
compromis oui on l'a vu d'ailleurs le
gouvernement provisoire qui a été
l'objet d'une attaque
lorsqu'il est revenu sur le sol yéménite
karim sader cette manoeuvre de
washington s'est clairement aussi contre
téhéran contre joe biden également
écoutez on est là dans un échange de
bons procédés entre l'administration 30
et si la lie du golfe arabie saoudite
t'attend évidemment le la décision est
totalement biaisé et puis le calendrier
est loin d'être anodin elle rentrera en
vigueur le 19 janvier c'est à dire à la
veille du match une fin officielle du
mandat de malpropres donc en quelque
sorte à m'appelle selman fidèle allié de
l'administration trump qui a rendu tant
de services à cette administration je
rappelle qu'il a cautionné le
rapprochement entre israël et ses
partenaires du golfe bahreïn et abu
dhabi
il a également donc rendu énormément de
services à l'administration américaine
donc se voit en quelque sorte par
exemple en autorisant lâchant du lest
vis-à-vis du qatar la semaine dernière
il ya quelques jours en mettant fin à l'
isolement du qatar pour faire justement
rendre service à washington et créer un
front uni contre l'iran donc je
m'appelle salman se voir aujourd'hui
gratifié de ses bons services
lui qui a été couvert jusqu'au pont par
l'administration trump après l' affaire
sordide de l'assassinât de rachi en
turquie donc c'est déjà une pierre
ducout pour l'administration printemps
on rend service à ses alliés dans la
région mais également vous l'avez selmi
ont mis le terrain avant la triste
fonction de la future administration
d'ambition à moins de dix jours
maintenant
pour sûr quelque sorte la mettre dans un
set accompli trotte ne veut pas que la
politique américaine au moyen-orient
fasse machine arrière
vis-à-vis de téhéran et font donc la
mettre dans cette espèce de fait
accompli
je crains bien sûr que tout cela ne ne
soit plus désavantageux sur le terrain
pour la population d'abord mais
également le risque aujourd'hui c'est de
voir avec des russie donc en quelque
sorte
étranglé par les sanctions le risque de
les voir encore plus jeter dans les bras
de téhéran et c'est là que c'est surtout
très contre-productif un point de vue
géopolitique karim ses nerfs pour bien
souligner que oui oui
vous parlez de situation humanitaire le
yémen qui est confronté à une menace de
pire situation en ce qui concerne la
famine la famine menace clairement le
pays aujourd'hui totalement mais étaient
les atouts de 80% de la population y est
même aujourd'hui dépend de l'aide
humanitaire
or aujourd'hui avec ces mécanismes de
sanctions vont venir s'ajouter encore
plus à l'incapacité justement des
organisations sur place à travailler et
à pourvoir pour opérer par exemple où
cette appli retravaillée de forêt pardon
dans les zones qui seront contrôlés par
les rues cycliques qui sont quand même
une sortie quand même une zone
considérable qui va de saada dans le
nord jusqu à sanaa qui a été triste donc
depuis quelques années par par des
rebelles
ainsi est le problème aussi c'est que le
même être encore plus pris en otage par
la régionalisation du conflit puisque je
le soulignais avec thérenty encore plus
proche de l'iran ce qui n'était pas
tellement le pas comme on veut car et
culturellement le parfois le démontrer
il n'y a pas beaucoup beaucoup de
similitudes idéologique entre les
ronciers 10 ans était à la une alliance
stratégique
or aujourd'hui les consignes isolé bon
encore plus si vite et dans les bras de
l'iran ce qui va encore plus prendre en
otage le yémen dans un conflit régional
sud chiite et c'est la population qui va
encore et toujours en payer le prix
atexo parvenir une résolution local du
conflit merci à vous karim sader d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france je rappelle que
vous êtes politologue spécialiste des
pays du golfe